it's 30 years this month since one of
the biggest disasters in british
business history
gerald ratner created the world's
largest chain of jewellery stalls
and in one speech he destroyed it
comparing his products to rubbish
he said a pair of earrings were cheaper
than a prawn sandwich and wouldn't last
as long
the speech bombed and his company nearly
collapsed though it wasn't the end of
his business career
we can speak to mr ratner now good
afternoon
to gerald i wonder if we can go back 30
years ago pre
this infamous now albert hall speech
what life what the world of gerald
ratner was like at that time
well we just announced profits of 125
million
the day before in fact we were going for
200 million in the in that year
we had two and a half thousand shops uh
we'd come
from sort of seven years ago a business
that was losing money
so everything was going extremely well
and then i was invited to make the
speech at the albert hall
made a couple of jokes and here we are
talking about it 30 years later
yeah i mean you talk about that the
business had been struggling a few years
previously it was seen as being
inaccessible it's been stuffy you
shifted the focus to affordability
you snapped up rivals you were seen as
having the midas
touch where were you planning to go
pre that speech
well we just uh you know we had a
thousand shops in america
that were doing very well we were one of
the few british retailers to succeed in
america
um we would define the recession as well
because in 1991
uh we were deep in the recession but we
were still doing extremely well
because of the fact that we were
offering um very low prices very
affordable jewelry
um which had never been never happened
before in the jewellery business jewelry
was always regarded as very expensive
the province of the rich we changed all
that we broke the threshold back
that's the sadness of the stupidity
of the speech because all that ended not
only for me but a lot of managers used
to come up to me
you know the age of 21 and say you know
i gave them a chance
um when nobody else would to run a shop
so you know it was a
absolutely unmitigating disaster
consequences of that speech
you must have gone over and over and
over this is countless
times but as you made the remark were
you aware
of how controversial it was going to be
that it was going down badly
not at all in fact it went down very
well everybody at the albert hall
took it the way it was supposed to be
meant that it was just a couple of jokes
to liven up the the speech um
the press said that i said it all about
my jewelry which i never mentioned my
jewelry i said
about one item of sherry decanter that
we acquired when we
bought h samuel um so no it was only
when you read the
tabloids the next day that it did look
terrible but i mean as i left the albert
hall
i didn't think anything was untoward and
um
i don't blame the press because the
press you know
always do that they're disingenuous and
you know good luck to them that's what
people want to read about
that you know they want a story that's
exaggerated somewhat
but um you know it was my own fault it
was a dumb joke to make i've made it
before
and people found it quite funny but on
this occasion
um they didn't find it well they found
it funny in the hall at the albert hall
but uh once they read it in the press or
the press's version of it
they didn't find it funny at all and
people uh stopped coming into our shops
and not only ratners but other
businesses that owned like h samuel
ernest jones watchers of switzerland
and so it had a devastating effect but
yeah and you say it was just meant as a
light-hearted joke but it was
perhaps the timing of this that hit hard
wasn't
it we were in recession people were
struggling to pay bills
you were seen as holding your customers
in contempt and that it was crass and
the result was
you lost everything yeah i did i lost
absolutely everything the shares went
down from four pounds twenty to two
payouts so my house take children out of
school
uh yeah i did i paid a very very high
price for it
but you know if anybody anyone who knows
me and all the managers who i still keep
in touch with and stuff like that
know that the one person that doesn't
have contempt for their customers
is me you know i adored my customers and
i gave them fantastic value for money
and that's what really hurts the fact
that people still list to this day on
twitter
say that um it was a joke
it was a joke that backfired big time
but
this talk about contempt for customers
making fun of them
uh is way off the mark and you're
absolutely right
we were deep in recession in 1991 people
couldn't pay their
electricity bills and stuff like that
and they were looking for a full guy
for this because the mood had changed
dramatically as i said because when i
made the joke
you know two or three years earlier it
was even actually printed in the sun
that same joke and the sons called it
what gerald's gems he's well known for
making jokes they are extremely funny
but that was when we were in a boom when
we were in a recession
they viewed it in a different way what
impact did it
have on you to go from the dizzy heights
to
nothing selling your house losing
everything how did you cope
with that sudden shift
well i didn't cope very well you know
the press said that i was unemployable
everyone was making jokes about me
and i sort of spent seven years lying in
bed watching countdown
i didn't want to play anymore i gave up
it was only when my wife threatened to
kick me out
uh that i went out and i the one thing
that was keeping me sane was cycling
which i still do to this day
25 miles a day um and the exercise has
helped me
through i helped a lot people through
this pandemic
so i really a believer in exercise and
then i started up a health club with no
money whatsoever
sold it two and a half years later four
million pounds
and it was the most wonderful feeling uh
to be back in business and to actually
be able to pay my bills again and not
have huge
bill you know bills that i couldn't pay
and being in this terrible situation
so you know i won't say that i um
i'm glad i made the the joke i far from
it but
i do appreciate things much more
nowadays after losing everything i think
that's human nature
and just quickly you also mentor others
what's your one bit of advice
to them gerald well yes i do do a lot of
mentoring
and i really enjoy it and i like to help
them and i think what i would
say to them is that you know if i can
come back
from the worst corporate disaster of all
time then if you have a setback don't
worry about it you'll come back as well
you know just keep trying you will get
knocked out
nobody will sell through life without
not having a setback
but in fact you know if you do have a
setback to a certain degree
you see people who haven't had setbacks
and they lack a certain amount of
sympathy and empathy
you know to be part of the human race
you've had to have suffered somewhat so
you know don't worry about it if things
go wrong business you can bounce back in
life you can bounce back